All right. Hello everyone. I'm Vivov.
Um, I work on BAML and this is AI that
works. And right here I have Dexter.
>> What's up? I'm Dex. I work on human a
company called Human Layer. Um, and uh,
this is AI that works. I know you
already said that, but I said it again
because uh, it's fun to say
>> it a lot better. So,
>> what do we do, Viv? What do we do on the
AI that works show? Why don't you fill
these fine people in?
>> Yes. The whole goal of this content is
as per usual to give everyone pieces of
work uh pieces of AI pipelines that
actually work and function beyond just
demo code and go in depth and talk about
technical stuff. Today's topic is a
topic that has been requested many many
times but I think it was related to what
we had talked about before with
interruptible agents and that inspired
this to come up again and that topic is
voice agents. How do we build voice
agents? We're gonna try and go ahead and
start off with general whiteboarding as
per usual. Then we'll show off some
code, but this episode I think is going
to be one of the most interactive ones.
So, if you guys have ever um worked on
voice agents, have thoughts about them,
have questions, keep the questions
coming in the chat, we will do our best
to make sure that we answer them in as
expedient of a matter as possible. If
you feel like we miss them, just send a
gesture our way using some of the emojis
or raise hand feature. We'll see them
for sure.
But with that, I'll let Dexter share his
screen and then we'll go straight into
whiteboarding.
>> Um, cool.
>> Cool.
>> It's a whiteboard. Um, cool. So, um,
Vib, you have the link to this, right?
>> Yes, I'm pulling it up right now as we
see.
>> I just don't have uh an extra monitor
right now, so I figured it's much better
if you're sharing.
>> Cool. Um
>> the question uh before you or while
you're doing your whiteboarding, why
would we build our own uh interruptible
agents and not use one of the uh
platforms that provide
agents, voice agents out of the box?
>> Well, I think I think that's a great
question. Like why not use a voice agent
out of a box? Um and I think it's the
same reason that you probably don't want
to build a voice agent. You don't want
to build a chatbot out of the box. While
you can use all these platforms to go do
things, I think it's it's good to be
able to choose to use a platform, but
you probably want to know what the
platform is doing under the hood. And
then if you find that what the platform
is doing is good for your needs, go use
it. It's actually great. But often
times, um, I think the first step is
often just knowing what's actually going
on under the hood. And that's what the
conversation today is about. The
trade-off is really product specific and
use case specific. So, we can talk more
about any specific idea after we're
after we discuss how a voice agent works
under the hood.
>> Thanks for asking.
>> Yeah, for what it's worth, they're like
way harder to build than chat bots
because there's a million more things
going on and the technology improved so
quickly. I spent like six months working
on voice agents and like if you build on
one specific platform like you're going
to get cooked. Um it's you're just going
to have a bad time. They all have
different weaknesses.
>> Yeah.
You're just waiting for them to catch up
with whatever the new tank or the new
model is.
>> Yeah. Like speech in speech out models
are like not good enough. They're just
not consistent at like structure
generation and tool calling. And what
you end up having to do is build a
pipeline where you have like a bunch of
different components including an LLM,
speech to text, text to speech, like
ideally a semantic VAD, an EOU machine
learning model, and it's a ton of other
stuff. And like you want to be able to
use the best for each one of those in
terms of like latency inconsistency and
pronunciation for your use cases. And
like no single platform is going to give
you the best option for all of those. So
you really need to like build a pipeline
that works for yourself.
>> Yeah. And this is all
>> sounds like Kyle is volunteering to lead
the follow-up episode on super advanced
voice agents.
>> And just to be really clear on this, the
caveat here is assuming that a voice
agent is critical to your business. If
it's not critical to your business, do
whatever you want. But if it is actually
critical to your business, like
everything else on AI that works,
understand how it works and then you can
do whatever you want with it. It's not
that hard. So the benefit a platform
gives you is really just time to market.
And if time to market comes at the cost
of accuracy, for some use case, that's
okay. But for almost everything else,
it's it's just not worth it.
Um, cool. Let's draw out the first part.
Oh, that is not what I meant to do.
Voice agents are weird and I think the
first weirdest thing about them is that
they operate on a timeline in a way that
very very few other systems do because
uh sadly voice conversations are just
monotonically continuing onwards and
they're just going to move forward in
time regardless of what your agent is
doing. And the reason that this ends up
happening is because if your if your
user talks to you at this what is going
on? How do I change that? Um that is not
a thing that I'll ever use. If your user
talks to you at this moment in time and
your voice agent later responds at this
moment in time. Oops. Um,
and your voice agent later responds at
this moment in time.
But while you're generating something,
the user generated a new message at some
time in this time period.
It's just not going to feel pretty for
the user. The other sad part about voice
agents is actually there's no such thing
as moments in time. I actually lied over
here. All of these are time periods.
Your voice, your user is going to be
talking for some duration. Your voice
agent is going to be responding for some
duration. Your user is going to be
interrupting for some duration.
and building in these control flows is
why the episode for um interrupts is
almost definitely the one that drove
this to a decision because in voice
agents interrupts are not optional to
design around. They are the primary
design mechanism you have to think about
at every single step of the way. And any
>> Go ahead, Dex.
>> Just to make that like a little more
concrete, like your agent would start
talking and then your user would start
talking and you'd have to detect the
start of this which would like create an
early end to this and then kind of
restart another agent response. And so
it's like you're you're like restering
in real time and it's not just like a a
singular stream of events. You kind of
have to moni monitor multiple streams in
parallel basically.
>> Exactly. And what you do really depends.
Maybe you want your agent to finish a
response and then pass this into the
user
>> and then respond again. Maybe you want
your agent to immediately stop, address
the user's concern, and then continue
onwards. But all of these things are
just caveats that are very important
design decisions that have to be made
because everything here is time chunks
and spans of time
and that I think makes the problem
infinitely harder than a simple chatbot.
The other problem is when you do a voice
agent UX is not your friend. The only UX
modality that most voice agents have
are purely voice. You can't you don't
have a screen. You don't have UXs where
you can pause input where you can like
gray out text boxes. You have no loading
spinners. You have only voice. So I
think in today's conversation what the
most important thing to talk about is
how are we going to
co-host
co-host mute Martin.
So I think today what we really want to
talk about is a couple of things. One,
how are we going to take the concepts
that we learned from the interrupt video
and apply them to voice agents? And then
two, how can we design UX so that it
doesn't feel as bad as just waiting for
a voice agent to go and respond with?
And I think those two techniques will
help us
hopefully build really, really amazing
voice agents along the way. And these
won't be the only two techniques, but I
think these are the two that we can
focus today's conversation on. The first
one Kyle already alluded to. Kyle's
already said this. Speech to speech
models are just not good. You can't you
can't do this yet. Um
you
>> Yeah, you can't context engineer them at
all because they're receiving like
>> audio tokens that Yeah. they that they
separate into like semantics and stuff
and then they generate tokens for audio.
Like you you have no ability to like
take a tool call and and transform, you
know, like you you just you you can't
own the input as well because it's it's
a lot more of a black box in terms of
how the model actually like sees the
prompt.
>> Exactly. So don't do this. It's not
worth your time. Um, I think you'll
I would wait for someone else to build
this out first and prove that it works
before you spend your time doing this is
the way I would describe this. Um, what
I would do instead is we still want to
have speech in, speech out, but we're
just going to break down this process
and simply
[Music]
make these much much smaller. Um, and
I'm doing these, by the way, by size
based on
um based on the size of the models.
Usually,
>> this is a text to speech
>> speech to text.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah, it's over there. Okay.
>> Speech to speech models also tend to be
like way more expensive
um based on like working with GPT4's
real-time model or Gemini's real-time
model. like they tend to be an order of
magnitude more expensive than the
corresponding text model. And part of
that's because you need like a stateful
birectional communication which usually
looks like web RTC or websockets and
stuff which is harder to scale. It's
stateful. It's harder to recover from if
something breaks or the user has a
disconnection. And so like there's all
kinds of really good reasons to not do
it. Like you could do a whole episode
just why to not use these things yet
because they're just not good enough.
And
>> exactly. So don't do it. uh you will
save yourself a lot of headache. Now
that said, if we do use speech to text
with an LLM and then a text to speech at
the end, we'll run into other problems
that are very tricky, which is how the
heck do we make this thing actually
good? Because if an LLM is sending data
out, how do you actually do how do you
actually stream audio out?
>> Well, there's a question.
>> Go ahead.
>> Um I would be really curious. you keep
saying good and you finish this point,
but I'd love to kind of just enumerate
three or four things that make a voice
agent good. Like what what are our kind
of capabilities that we're after here?
>> That's actually a great that's a great
call out, Dexter. I think when I use a
voice agent, the number one thing that I
look for is really this is um
concreteness. I'll use very concrete
examples uh examples first, which is
latency. I just want it to say stuff to
me uh correctly. Like I want it to say
stuff to me fast so I'm not waiting for
it all the time. I want
>> the pause when I say something and then
there's a two second pause because the
language model is thinking. That sucks.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like that's okay on a
loading spinner in a chat app. It's not
okay when I'm talking to something
>> because it doesn't feel human.
>> It's not. It It feels worse than like
the control flow that I used to use with
like a phone pad because at least there
I can just press nine and eight and move
to the menu section I want. Here I have
to like wait forever. And that is like
if you've ever if you've ever used like
a phone book that says press one for
English, press two for Spanish and you
have to listen to the whole thing before
you can press one. That is the most
frustrating experience ever.
>> Uh and this is like prevoice models. So
like now it's just even longer because I
knew
>> Okay, cool. So So there's also like
interruptability of just like I don't
want to hear what the rest of you have
to say. Just take me to the next step.
>> Ex and that's kind of but I bundle all
that with latency because
interruptability is like a uh what I
said but I really what I want is I just
want latency to be really I want to feel
fast in how I communicate and I I
personally value that much more than
accuracy. But accuracy comes as a close
uh as a close um second
>> which is like it it's correct and high
quality.
>> Exactly. It just has to be correct and
high quality. And lastly, honestly, it
just vibes. Like when you when you use a
voice model, I feel like you can just
tell that something is really good. If
you've ever used
um if you've ever used one of those ones
that have gone viral online, like the
ones where um
there's this one that went viral a while
ago where you would text it and
basically you would give it access to
everything and it would try and just
like uh troll you when you spoke to it.
I can't remember the name of it. Uh but
my cousin had showed me. And when I saw
it, I was like, "This is kind of dumb."
But then when I actually used it, it
actually felt really good because it
spoke to me like a friend would be
speaking to me if I was 20. Um, it had
perfect Gen Z slang. And I don't mean
like the chatbt Gen Z where it adds the
emoji all the time, but I mean genuinely
spoke like friends in his phone book
would speak. And it did this by copying
his email, copying his Slack, copying
his um, Twitter and just getting full
access to it. So it just felt very, very
human. it felt like it had a real
personality to itself.
Um, and I think that's the last part of
what makes a great voice agent,
something with a real personality.
>> One of the main things that contributes
to vibes, too, is like how
conversational the agent is. And um
that's not just like people will think
that that's just like how good the text
to speech is and how emotive and
expressive it is, but like the it one of
I think the biggest determinance of like
the vibes of it. And like this will make
a really good agent awful or like a
decent one like really good is how well
it actually handles interruptions.
>> Yeah. Um, and this is like one of the
reasons you shouldn't use a platform,
um, is like a lot of speechtoext like
streaming transcription models like
Deepgram, um, will tell you, hey, the
user finished talking now, but they're
not great at it and it's really
unreliable. Even if your agent or your
like your u voice activity detection and
end of utterance detection are like 95%
accurate, that's still a really really
really bad user experience. And the best
voice agents are using custom machine
learning models
like OpenAI recently introduced semantic
voice activity detection that's not just
like looking at the audio waveform to
figure out is this a person talking or
is this a waveform
like a door slamming or something. Um,
and then for end of utterance, like you
want to figure out, not just, oh, did
the user stop talking because you could
look at the waveform to do that, but the
user might have just paused for a second
or two while they're thinking or while
they're like looking up information, you
know, um, like a lot of end of utterance
models that aren't like really good
semantic models will just say, "Oh, the
user stopped talking for half a second,
start generating the LLM response, and
that results in the LLM interrupting the
person in the middle of a thought." And
so there's really good models out there
now like live kit has some good
offtheshelf ones um that you can use for
end of utterance that actually like
semantically looks at you know not just
oh did the audio stop but is this
actually the end of an utterance or is
the like is this in the middle of like
some semantic expression like a thought
because that will result that makes the
difference between a like the model
thinking that it got interrupted when
it's just background noise and and so it
will stop talking in the middle of
saying something and the user gets
frustrated really quickly. And also um
like the difference between um you know
it interrupting you all the time because
you talk slowly or because you pause
sometimes or you had to go look
something up and it gets in a loop and
like it interrupts you and you weren't
done talking so you like
>> start talking before and it just gets
into a really bad cycle. So, like those
are also really key parts of the vibes
thing is just like does it actually
really really really like grock like the
conversation and not just like oh audio
started audio stopped.
>> Exactly.
>> What what was it the model that you
recommended Kyle? Can you drop it in the
chat?
>> Yeah, Live Kit's a platform. They have
some good models. There's really good
models for it on Hugging Face. Like I
don't have a specific recommendation
about them. I've used a couple of them.
Um,
>> all right. We'll get some we'll get some
links and put them in the show notes
afterwards so you can check them out on
GitHub.
>> Um,
>> perfect. All right. Bye, Bob. Back to
back to what we're building.
>> Yeah, this goes back to what what I
think makes a voice agent good, but
everyone has their own opinion. So, once
you can define your own opinion, you can
tweak rubrics accordingly. Um, but now
let's go back to what it actually takes
to make a pipeline. So, the first thing
is we agree that we're not going to go
use a speech to speech model. We're
going to use speech to text, LM, and
text to speech. Now, the problem with
this is this is naturally a highly
latent pipeline. No matter what you do,
you're going to add latency here. So,
what can we do to make this better?
Well, there's a couple of things. Well,
the first thing that we can do, and I
don't know if I'm not actually sure if
cursor does this for sure, but I
wouldn't actually be surprised if they
don't do this,
which is you can actually add in gaps
when you're when you're running stuff.
So the first hack to latency is actually
to
pretend like you have no latency. If any
of you know what uh in Instagram did
when they first got famous uh with their
image uploads, as soon as you selected
the image, they started uploading it to
their back end. And then if you chose
not to actually publish it, they would
just discard it from their back end and
throw it away. But if you did publish
it, they would actually have it and
they'd be like people would be like,
"How the heck is Instagram uploading my
images so fast? The magic was they just
started uploading data much much faster.
The trick to having better latency is
literally to start speaking before the
LM starts generating tokens. You will
have better response times no matter
what you do. So for example
>> that there's some common common phrases
that are pretty good. Sure, let me take
a look or such variants of this.
You could tell the LLM
that you are going to start, you're in
your prompts, you could indicate that
you're going to start with some phrase
and the phrase can be a variable of some
kind that you swap out between like 70
or 100 hard-coded phrases that you can
just code gen in the beginning.
And you just have the model go say this
in a pre-recorded voice ahead of time.
And once this is done,
you then tack on the rest of your text
with an outline.
>> Okay. So, in this in this case, your
context window might look like um you
have like your user message of like,
hey, the example I'm doing is like a a
voice assistant for like a a doggy
daycare. So, it's like, hey, I want to
board my dog. And then you would speak
this.
And then you would send to the LLM.
Sure. Let me take a look
as the so we'll call her assistant
messages and user messages.
And then you would send this to the LM
and say, "What's the next message?" And
then the LM would say like, "I'd be
happy to it looks like we have
availability or whatever it is." Uh
>> exactly.
and and and so and so and and I guess
you would send you would send this as
soon as the user p pasted their message
you would send this context window and
then it would speak this and so the
latency to first token you would wait
till it's done speaking this and then if
you started having token stream back in
then you could start speaking
immediately
>> exactly
and like this thing takes like a second
like one point the cool thing about
voice actually that I've noticed that I
actually find to be a interesting Plus
is as a medium
most voice takes longer than you think.
Sure. Let me take a look. Is like a 4 to
5 second is like a 4 second utterance.
So what you did is you almost bought
yourself 4 seconds of time by default by
having that sentence be spoken
because you can say it slightly slower
as an agent like sure let me take a look
for you. Or hold on a second I'm looking
up some stuff. Even small phrases like
that have baked in latency. You don't
even have to pass them in as context if
you don't want to. It just makes it flow
better and the vibes gets better if you
do.
But you've now
>> I have a I have a quick question on
this. So I'm assuming you're doing this
in streaming mode. You're not
essentially waiting for the LLM to
complete everything and then show it
back to the user. One of the hardest
things I've found there, like I think
the latency hiding part makes a lot of
sense, but when you actually
set up the streaming, you kind of have
to define these stop words or at what
point should the LLM start to respond,
right? So, how do you set that up? I I
have always found that to be very
challenging, like should it look for
punctuations or some sort of words?
Could you speak more about that if if
that's on the agenda?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So what do you could you
repeat the question one more time on
you?
>> Uh sure. So um if you set uh this up in
streaming mode, you kind of have the
opportunity to define um at what point
should the chunking happen of the user's
input and there are multiple ways to do
that chunking. How do you recommend we
do that chunking?
>> You mean for the actual text that you're
sending back to the user?
No, no, no. For for um the when the user
is speaking, you could either wait till
the end of the users like users turning
over or you could chunk it up and start
sending it already. So, what what's your
recommendation there?
>> I think it depends on what trade-off you
want to make. If you don't care at all
about money, honestly, what I would do
is I would just send it like every
single time you get like a utterance of
some kind where your users made some
semantic statement like kind of what
Kyle was alluding to using those models,
you just send it every single time. But
>> okay, so then if half a second later
your turn detection model says, "Okay,
now the user is done speaking." You
gained half a second there because you
already sent the last token out.
>> Exactly. So you and this is again this
is assuming you don't care at all about
money. We're purely optimizing for
latency, accuracy, and vibes. I have not
I didn't say cost in that equation at
all. So I'm throwing that away. And but
the trick here is not to actually not to
actually um um send the response back to
the user at all times
because anytime the LM fires off, what
ends up happening is the user starts
talking and let's just assume that this
the entire user block and the user
speech pattern looks something like
this. There's a little pause in the
middle. Um and then we got we detected
like somewhere around here. Um somewhere
around here is when we detected that uh
hey the user ended semantically and we
also detected that ended semantically
over here and then we also detected that
they ended semantically around here and
then they rean their speech around here
and then we detect that there was
another semantic end over here.
So what you would gain over here is you
would have technically fired off an LM
call. Whoops.
You would fire one LM call on here at
this point. You'd fire another LM call
over here at this point. Fire a third
one here and a fourth one here.
And then it becomes your job to think
about which one of these is the most
semantically relevant and which one of
them are actually going to go ahead and
do a good job. So for example, it's very
>> So when this one when this one finishes,
you would say, "Oh, but we detected they
already started speaking again." And so
you like basically end up throwing all
three of these out and then using this
one, right?
>> Or
>> or what you could say is one thing that
you'll notice is maybe all the user said
at the very end was at the very end over
here was something very simple like okay
and everything in here didn't actually
matter. It didn't contribute in any
meaningful way. It just meant that it
was just like a culmination thing. If
you're able to quickly detect that the
thing over here didn't semantically
change to anything or add new
information, you can actually just use
the first one.
>> So the question over here like we so
this is the typical way of doing doing
this. But what if we were able to just
so so thinking about it as how humans
speak, right? So can't we just have a
system where the LLM once so the user is
talking talking now the LLM has enough
information or context to to reply. So I
mean we can just we can just start the
conversation there. So where so once you
have enough enough information to to
give a response back to the user and
also have other cues like emotion
detection within the voice too right
>> the problem that you run into there
Sahil is if you're a business and you're
running you're and you're running this
like the most common use case for voice
agents right now is like booking orders
of some kind or like sale support agents
or something the thing is all of those
like sales and support are very very
cautious roles, you really don't want
your support agent to be super
aggressive with the customer like and
just like be like, "Oh, did you do this?
Did you do this? Did you do this?"
That's a bad feeling. So, you'd actually
prefer to be more in the cautious side
rather than the aggressive side of pro
having speech happen.
So, while you're right, we could do a
background test of going to go listen,
we want to be as fast as possible, but
at the same time, we want to make sure
that we are not interrupting. We want to
minimize interruptions from the agent
side. We want the human to interrupt us,
but we don't want the agent to be
interrupting the human very often.
>> Okay. Um, we're at 30 minutes and I
think we got a tight hour going today.
So, um, I'm going to say let's let's
pause on questions. Drop your questions
in the chat. I'll keep an eye on them
and let's talk about the supervisor
threading thing and we'll say we'll have
at least 10 minutes to look at the code
and then we'll have 10 minutes at the
end for questions.
>> Exactly. So this kind of leads us into
the next part which is like when you're
going to have a voice conversation flow
we are going to naturally go off track.
So right in here in this optimistic LM
call thing that we saw we saw that we
could have started LM call the user said
something meaningless in the last 5
seconds um and therefore we have to go
delay and then run another call. But if
we ignore that, we technically could
have all the data we need to respond
with as early as possible, and we could
respond much much faster. We could use
call one instead of call two. Oops.
We could use call one instead of call
two because call two really added
nothing beyond the okay. So, we can
ignore call two. We lost some money.
That's okay. We just abort the call. We
stopped spending money on that one.
What's really interesting about this in
my opinion is the key part depends on
being able to detect that the part okay
is actually a totally meaningless thing
in terms of content creation. This is
very very very similar to exactly how
you want to do interrupts in longunning
context or longunning conversation
flows. What you want to do in a very
very longunning agent is you want to
have your timeline. You want to have
your agent talking. You want to have
your human talking. And maybe there's
some overlap. That's okay. Oops. Uh,
sorry, I don't have my mouse today, so
I'm slightly uglier on my drawings,
Dexter.
Um,
>> you are all you got nothing to apologize
for.
>> Human agent all the way through. And
there'll be some exchanges over here.
um and conversations will happen. But we
kind of want to have a separate we want
almost want to have a separate agent
that's running in the background every
single time the human says something or
at some fixed cadence
that is going to think for some longer
period of time to
smart agent or supervisor agent. We can
call it whatever makes sense. Dexter
>> I will call it the supervisor.
>> Okay,
>> since that's what the code says. Yeah,
that's basically monitoring the task to
help the main agent
actually resteer itself. And what we'll
do is every time the supervisor detects
that something is off, what it will do
is regardless of what the human is
saying, regardless of what the agent is
saying, if the supervisor says something
is off,
we will take the previous conversation
thread
at the snapshot point that the that the
uh that the supervisor agent was kicked
off. So in this case, it's it's right
after this agent call. Can I make one
change to this real quick? I think the
super agent visor agent is probably
reviewing what the agent says, right?
So, it kind of starts here.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Um, and for the purpose of
this, can we do it right uh can we can
we um can we do it right after the
second call? I think it'll be more uh
clear.
>> Okay, cool. That's fine.
>> So, what we're going to do is we're
going to delete what the human said.
The supervisor agent is going to say
something went wrong. So we're going to
keep our conversation history, our
context window built in with everything
up in the conversation until this
conversation point. Then we are going to
inject a a placeholder.
At this point,
>> something like, "Oh, wait. Actually," or
like, "Sorry, one sec." Or whatever it
is.
>> I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm sorry. I
think I may have may gone off track.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you give
me a few seconds to
uh confirm?
>> And this is basically your super advisor
agent when it's done is going to output
like either on track or off track.
>> Exactly.
And you can see how a specifically what
I've done here is the placeholder is
actually pretty long.
But it's also immediately gives the user
context on what happened, which is it
thinks that we made a mistake of some
kind. It thinks that we want to go off
track. Uh it thinks that we want to go
recollect and collect some more
information and it's going to go and go
do that. And once this happens,
we're going to take the information.
We're going to kick off another thread
from a larger uh model of some kind
which is going to take the previous
context. It's going to take the most
recent human message on top of that.
It's going to take all the stuff we
need. Uh I don't know how to build
arrows. I can't do arrows on my current
machine, Dexter. Sorry.
It's going to take all the thing that
were detected as need changes. It's
going to take the most recent human
message on top of that self
and then it's going to help. It's going
to try and produce a response of some
kind.
>> Yeah. So, that would be something like,
"Yeah, before I can book you, actually,
I need to get your email before I can
take any more details or whatever it
is."
>> Exactly. And we still want to have the
context of the most recent human message
that came on because that's what's going
to make it feel so much more natural in
addition to and then say and we want the
prompt over here to be something like
um the conversation seems to be slightly
off track
needs
changes
green text.
>> Yeah, let me I'm I'm curious because
this is similar to the demo that I uh
put together.
>> Um but let me let me actually pop into
the code and I'll show you the prompt
that we give the agent.
>> Um
>> that's actually probably even a better
thing to help people see exactly what we
mean because we'll pseudo code this, but
I have the real code so we might as well
show that off. Yeah, let's just look at
this and um it'll and then we'll pop
back to the whiteboard and we can
whiteboard out a little bit more um just
so you have the exact details. So we
have a small model which is GPTOSS
uh running on Cerebrris. Um the small
model the voice model the thing powering
that the most important thing there is
you want it to be really really fast
right you want it to be able to time to
first token fast and just generate text
quickly.
>> So um
>> because we want to we don't do any of
the latency tricks. We don't do any of
that stuff. Instead we just use
Cerebrris which is probably one of the
fastest time to first tokens out there
and we use a very small model 12B. So we
don't have to do latency hiding because
basically the only latency we have is
network and that's uh acceptable in
almost every use case.
>> Yep. And then we have GPT5 as our kind
of slower more thinky supervising model.
And so the actual um
>> functions
>> the actual like code oh yeah let's let's
go to the functions. Um so I actually
didn't end up using this yet. So I'm
going to leave this commented out. Um
but we have the small one. I also I had
to name the assistant Tony because when
I was pasting in this one this was this
was wild. Uh when I was pasting in the
uh the thread I was like hey this thread
didn't connect right and it said user
assistant user assistant the model
actually went and like claude code
started continuing the conversation. It
saw user and assistant and it was like
okay so the the supervisor and the uh
the the model's name is Tony so that it
said Tony instead of assistant. But
anyways, um the point is is say we say,
"Okay, be conversation helpful. Here's
the conversation so far and respond as
the assistant with your next message
only."
>> Um and the way this actually gets
generated out is uh I'm going to turn on
real quick.
>> Before we go run this, do before you
actually run this, do you want to run
the
>> do you want to show me the do you want
to show the prompt?
>> U Oh yeah, the supervisor agent prompt.
So this is like you're an AI supervisor
who picks up the phone of of Tony who
picks up the phones. Here's the rules,
right? Always get the user email address
before confirming any booking. If like
the answer must be that you have these
vac vaccines, never provide legal
advice. So these are all the things that
the supervisor model is going to get the
conversation.
Uh and so the prompt is you know review
the conversation below. So the user is
like here's the conversation and then
here's the instructions and then we give
it the output format. And so the prompt
here looks like Sorry, go ahead.
>> And one thing I want to call out here is
like we we basically do our best not to
spend a lot of time prompt engineering
this. And the reason for that is like we
just throw it at a bigger model. We just
toss GVD5. It's okay if it runs slow.
Who cares?
>> Cuz like the the main task is going to
run real fast. So it's okay.
>> Yep. And then we say either respond with
on track or needs adjustment with a
message. And then here's the schema
we're responding. So we have it when it
decides you need adjustment, it actually
includes the correction message right
there. And it always has to start with
like 08 actually.
>> Um and so
let's see. Um yeah, we can run this one.
So this was like I want to I want to
board my cat. So like I said, hey, like
I want to like where is it? One of these
like oh I need to board my cat. And the
assistant says like sure I can help you
board your cat. What dates are you
looking for? And then the supervisor is
supposed to say, "Actually, we only care
for dogs." And so this gets injected
into the context window as part of it.
Um, I can show you a little demo here.
Um, and I'm going to leave the BAML logs
on. This is just text to text. Um,
>> another awesome debugging thing that
Dexter did here is in his voice agent,
he actually built a text mode because it
is very hard to debug voice only agents.
So like one nice caveat about having
speech to text text to voice is you can
add the modes very easily by having
those models in there and you don't have
to always use voice.
>> So this says it's on track because it
actually did the smart thing and said we
don't board cats here. Um but let me
control C this. I'm going to turn the
BAML logs off so you can see a little
bit more
detail.
No, he's a great
Okay. Um,
>> you should tell it. You should say you
should say your boss.
Yeah, there you go.
>> Uh,
>> all model will eventually be dumb.
>> Um, okay. So, here is the supermodel
supervisor model. This one's actually a
little bit buggy because it only checks
for supervisor injections on the next
assistant message uh because I built
this in a hurry. Um but you can see it's
coming through and saying actually we
only board dogs here. Um and here's the
message to say. So this code is a little
bit janky, but if you want we can try
the voice mode and see see what happens.
>> Let's let's do that Dex. Let's just show
that off really fast. I want to show a
little bit more about how the threading
models work here.
Um, and I haven't actually tested the
speech to the the text to speech side of
this.
He's uh 45 pounds and he is a uh he's
actually not a dog. He's a cat.
Okay. Uh anyways, this is uh
we're gonna we're gonna not mess with
this too much.
>> Um but now now you have the format in
the prompts. Is there any other code
parts you want to check out?
>> Yeah, there's well if we go back to the
whiteboard, I want to talk about one or
two more things really fast.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I think one of the one or two of the
things that I really want to talk about
is a threading model that goes onto here
when you go build this out. Um, a really
really important part about this and we
touched on this again in the interrupt
video is really the threading of how
often you run the supervisor agent. So
the implementation that Dex was working
on was an implementation that runs a
supervisor agent on every agent message
that comes across.
You can do that. That basically is
infinite cost uh that scales to this
that is very hard to regulate um and do
things on. Another thing you can do is
you can actually instead just run the
supervisor agent once every 15 seconds
assuming that or once every 5 seconds or
once every 10 seconds assuming that a
message has happened.
The other thing you can do is you can
optionally turn on and off the
supervisor agent during critical parts
of your pipeline. So if you have a
pipeline that is for example doing form
collection that might be an area where
you want to turn on the supervisor
because you really care about the form
collection being perfect. Um and if the
form collection ever goes wrong it just
doesn't work in any meaningful way. So
um
>> and you could have different supervisor
agents right you could have one that's
just checking for compliance and another
one that is like hey make sure that
there are no typos in the data collected
and things like that and make sure the
email looks like a real email and all
that stuff. So when you go do this, I
think we that's why the supervisor agent
name somewhat kind of irks me. I was
just like calling it like a validation
agent of some kind and like each
validation agent has some specific kind
of like thing that it validates for and
it might have multiple things it
validates for at the same time. Um but
in general this is um this is what I
find works really well having like a
treating list like a multi-threaded
process where you're choosing how many
threads you want to run and parallel at
any given time on what messages you want
to run threads on. You can do something
more specific which is like hey what I
actually have is I have like a
classifier uh that runs at the very top
and based on the classifier I pass it on
to different supervisors for every
message that passes through
uh along the way. So I actually have
like I have my I have my like
legal disclaimer. I have other things
going on and then I pass it in
accordingly. And you can build this
system. You can instead of think of the
system really as a supervisor, what I
like to think of it as is I highly
highly recommend think of this as more
like a workflow. What all you're really
building here is given the status of
some conversation flow that is going on.
I want you to analyze it and determine
some way to define the state of this
conversation.
>> Yeah, you you're basically building out
a state machine and there's all these
different transitions whether it's like
supervisor interrupting or like like
small model correcting itself or
something else.
>> Yeah, sorry. Just to be very very
specific on what I was saying is what I
mean is once this agent human
conversation is being built out all a
supervisor thread really is
I'm going to copy and paste this
It's basically in introspection
into some flow of conversation happened
that's frozen in time. It has no updates
given to at any given point and whether
and and just you're just looking at the
status of this to be like what is what
is true about this conversation.
>> Okay. And then you can have you can have
that be like classify as one of three
things. You can say create a summary.
You can say evaluate which rules are
give me a list of rules that are broken.
whatever it is.
>> Exactly. And that's all a supervisor is.
And now what you need to decide as an
engineer is just how often you want to
run this function that takes a
conversation history and snaps it back.
And then
>> and in just to be extra clear, like in
reality, the context window we send to
our supervisor agent is actually like,
hey, you're a supervisor. There's some
text here. And then in one of your user
messages, you say, here's the
conversation so far.
>> Yeah. But it doesn't even have to be it
doesn't even have to be a full uh it
doesn't even have to be a single agent.
It could be like seven different agents
that all have different prompts that all
have different context. It doesn't even
matter.
>> Some you for some agents you might only
want to give them the last two seconds
of context.
>> For another agent, you might want to
give it the immediate you might want to
give it the whole context over the
lifetime of the user. And that's a thing
you might want to run like once every
minute because it takes forever to run.
There's so many different ways to go
define this that I would say that I
wouldn't really
um I wouldn't even pin the name uh
supervisor to it because that implies
that's a single function that's running.
You might I would view this as a very
complex pipeline that you will build
over time and I think a lot of people
say eval are their secret sauce. I think
for voice agents this part of your
pipeline is your secret sauce. This is
the secret sauce for every single voice
agent. How well can you steer the
conversation on the fly? And then
depending on how you represent state at
this time. So like Dextra has a thing
that represents one type of state is
like on track versus needs changes
and then there's like a string attached
to this possibly of like what changes it
needs. That's one type of uh status that
we have. You could have tons of other
statuses of like what is this user
doing? what what is this what is going
on in this conversation at any given
time and then you as an engineering team
could actually build a real-time
dashboard that actually shows you the
flow of a conversation over time. So
what I really would want to see if I was
building this type of voice agent is not
a lot of people build like DX on like
what is a voice agent along the way.
They say the conversation none of that
matters. What I really want to see is I
want to see snapshots of in Dex's case
what I would love to see snapshots of
the supervisor agent showing me the
conversation
and literally showing me the points in
time when it went from green. How do I
fill this in? green
to red where it went off track. And I
just want to see a timeline of how often
this happens. And the KPI that I would
be tracking
is
how much of the time is a supervisor
agent spending on time versus off off
task. And that is the KPI that I should
be tracking from my voice agents. And if
I can do that,
>> so you're sending this chunk and then
you're sending this chunk and then
you're sending this chunk. And basically
just like when whenever whenever it gets
back on track and that's your that's
your eval. your KPI of like how good is
this agent at at least at following the
rules, right? The making the experience
for the user good is like that's our
like optimization as far as like how do
we build a good product, but our KPI is
like we need to make the user the
experience for the user as good as
possible without like giving people
medical advice when we shouldn't be.
>> Exactly. And then I might want to have
metrics on like what kind of things does
it go off track on? does it go off track
on legal issues by giving legal advice
and that's why my supervisor agent
triggers and once I can figure out what
stuff is triggering then I can go ahead
and like minimize some of those and say
okay I definitely don't want the main
agent to going on legal stuff so let me
go modify my main agent's prompt to go
emphasize that it shouldn't go on legal
tangents because it seems to be doing
that a lot definitely shouldn't be
directly scheduling because it didn't
call the tool call correctly well in
that scenario great let me go fix that
problem and you and actually make sure
that instead of scheduling this tool
anytime scheduling gets anytime the main
agent tries to schedule anything I have
a really lightweight supervisor agent
perhaps another 120B model that's
running or even a 20B model that's
running to see is it scheduling without
calling a is it scheduling without
calling a scheduling tool call
>> right instead of having all of those
like here's 10 rules tell me yes or no.
It's like cool. Classify each of those
rules in a separate parallel call to a
really small LLM of just like is the
model giving medical advice? Is the
model XYZ? Is it okay?
>> Exactly. But I don't want to go do that
on day one because then it's going to
make my system very heavyweight. So I'm
going to I'm going to slowly
incrementally build that up from day z
from day zero. And I would do exactly
what Dexter did, which is have one agent
in the beginning and that one supervisor
agent that has a bunch of promps
that I'm gonna have one giant
scheduleuler uh supervisor agent with a
giant prompt and then I want to build a
dashboard for my team to look at every
conversation in a timeline view with
colors just to know how off track and
how on track it went
and then the minute that that happens I
want to go ahead and just go and
optimize accordingly based on real data
real conversations because there's no
prompt optimizations you can do by just
listen to the whole conversation. If any
of you have ever looked at post hog like
screen recordings for your website or
any other system, the most useful part
in those screen recordings is actually
not the screen recording. It's the part
where they skip the eight hours of
inactivity.
Like you need to go and find the events
in your voice agent to go build them
out. The rest of the actual stuff of
like writing this code out is like super
super easy. The actual code is like we
all know how to write a function. Can
you scroll up Dexter?
>> Yep.
We all know how to write a function that
says where one of the inputs is a
conversation of some kind and I want to
go figure out what like describe this
conversation status to me. That's a data
extraction problem. You write a class
model that says I want to know the shape
of this data in terms of how on track is
it? Does it give legal advice? Does it
do XYZ?
But and that's just an LM prompt. We can
go do that. We might want to use like
maybe with some old classical
techniques. Maybe we use like keywords
to be like, "Hey, is the model shouting
obscenities just by looking at it?" And
any
>> that's I mean that's what we do in old
like automated phone trees, right? If
the user is swearing, we immediately
divert you to a human.
>> Exactly. So you can do all sorts of
things like this along the way. But that
stuff is just standard code. You don't
have to learn anything new. The key part
to a voice agent is the threading model
that you need to think about and just
spin it off in a background thread and
build an interrupt workflow that takes
the learnings from this state and
somehow resets the context window with
something like I'm sorry I have to go
off track and generates a new message so
that you can go back on track to what
the user might want and two learn how to
build evals for voice agents which is
really can you scroll down which is
really more about understanding the
highle level flow of a conversation. And
sadly, there's no shortcut there. You
you just have to go build out like a a
colorized view of your timeline almost.
Um, and most people don't actually build
the colors. Most people have no idea how
often they get off track. They use and
vibes are really, really good when
you're listening to one or two
conversations.
But like, if you're lucky enough to
actually have like over 100, 200 real
customer conversations, just plot it.
And the minute you have over 100, 200,
plotting is going to do way better work
for you than anything else can.
>> Yep.
>> Um, lot of comments, not a lot of
questions here. Um, can we use similar
supervisor to compact the context so
when the conversation goes really really
long, we don't need to pass in all the
messages. Great question.
>> Yes, the answer is yes, you can. And you
definitely should be doing that. Um, but
you can think of it like a form filling
question if you've ever done that. Have
have have you ever written a form
filling agent of your menu?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
>> Yeah. So, it's the same thing. Once you
have a form filling agent, you're kind
of instead of even having the whole
conversation, you can just replace a lot
of the previous messages with just the
current form is this, what is the next
form? And that's kind of like compaction
in some sense. A
>> kind of almost a better compaction than
anything you could have.
>> It's
Go ahead. No, I was just saying like in
cases where it's very clear what that
artifact is that you're trying to get
out of the conversation, it's very
simple. That's the artifact that gets
preserved throughout the conversation
and nothing else.
>> Yeah. The the harder part is when you
have a more ambiguous artifact. What I
recommend in those scenarios is see if
you can have the user guided through
some checkpoints. I think the mistake
that people make with voice agents is
the same is very similar to what they do
with chat aid bots. If you have a
>> one prompt for the whole conversation
instead of having like phased like
different LM based prompts for different
like parts of the conversation and
checkpoints.
>> Exactly. So as long as you can have some
sort of checkpoints in your conversation
of some kind and you can always have
some like save point that you can always
revert back to if something goes
horribly wrong and I find that to be
very very useful
>> for any
>> So this would take you to like a
structured output.
>> Yeah. And often
>> and this becomes part of the input to
the second agent which has like a new
prompt. Yeah. And often I wouldn't say
every tool call is a good point for a
structured output or like a checkpoint,
but some specific tool calls are great
um like uh checkpoints. So for example,
like if you're booking an appointment,
collecting information, doing all that
stuff is not a great checkpoint, but the
minute you've booked an appointment or
like the minute you're going to confirm
with the user whether or not they want
to book an appointment, that is a great
checkpoint.
So like you could naturally think about
this based on the flow of your
conversation of what what you would do
here. Uh and then build that out. Uh the
second part that I would think about
when you go do this is actually about
UX. I actually I think sometimes people
expect uh their users to have no
tolerance for anything. But honestly, if
I've been on the call for like five
minutes with an agent for a long time,
and five minutes isn't that long, but
even fi at five or 10 minutes, and then
you as an agent told me, "Hey, this
conversation's actually getting quite
long, we're going to use a slightly long
bigger model, so you may have slightly
slower response times from now on, I
think I would forgive you as a as a
software, not be upset at you at doing
that. But if you didn't tell me that and
you suddenly started taking a lot
longer, I would be very annoyed." Um, so
I think having transparency with your
users is a great way to solve that
problem as well. Uh, if you don't want
to compact the window.
Amazing. Y'all, this was super fun.
We'll get this posted. Uh, thank you,
Vibb, for calling in from Berlin. I know
it's late there. Um, appreciate all of
you all. The code is already live. We're
going to clean up the GitHub repo. We'll
get the uh video and stuff pushed out by
uh ideally I think probably sometime
tomorrow.
>> Yes. Um it might not be tomorrow, but it
might be the day after, but it will be
live soon. Uh oh, Germany time, but I
guess maybe tomorrow PST time. Um and
then uh we'll probably get another
sample set of some of the more uh fun
stuff with actual interrupting and
everything uh when I'm back from back in
the States and we do another episode on
it. Um, and hopefully we'll have more
writing code available then as well.
>> Yeah. Um, sounds great. All right, dude.
Thank you. Thanks everybody. See y'all
next week.
>> Adios, everyone. See you.